aubry plaza was on the show the other
night and she was talking about uh
the and about the movie and she's
one person i'm a fan she she is uh
i would think that she's quite
unpredictable in how she behaves
you know because for example i heard
that well she is i
even whenever i i love aubry whenever i
talk to her i never know
which character we never know which way
it's going to go and it's always
entertaining because she's such an
original yeah
i saw you guys uh your episode together
yeah and she's really fun
uh and i was just curious because i know
that this this story is based on really
real two brothers yes they're called the
stangle brothers mike
mike and david dave stangle these are
real brothers that wanted to
get uh wedding dates off craigslist and
that's what you guys have based the
movie on
and you know some movies it's like they
need to make a movie about mandela
or lincoln and sometimes you need to
make a movie about two brothers that
just want to get a date
and i think it's the same who's to say
which is the more important movie
i see we'll see but the academy we'll
see
yeah i'm starting my campaign now
yeah i love that they yeah
but aubry uh i heard that the stangles
came and they hung out on set and that
aubrey was
is this true she was a little
inappropriate with them oh yeah she just
uh
you know they're they're like they're
like like like how tall are you about
six four yeah bigger than that
and um okay no they're big they're big
guys
uh and so she kept wanting to see their
dicks
what i i guess yelling that she's like
show your dicks
as a joke but then the rest of us are
like yeah are they huge what's going on
you know
because they're eye level they're like
they're it's right here the whole time
by the way i
i i was not that doesn't mean that it's
well it's right there so we might as
well
see it since when does ease of access
have anything to do with well then we
should see it
i guess we live different lives
and also he doesn't know aubry that well
yeah yeah um but i
i was not there for this what like i
think some crazy weird stuff goes on
whenever you and
i think you say that you're not around
for these things i that seems very
suspicious to me
i was like that incident if i i'm not
going to see what it's about to just say
uh you kind of have to like when a crap
hot dog it was close to that it was
close to something like that